LOINC was developed and is maintained by
the Regenstrief Institute in Indiana,
but is used virtually worldwide.
Each code is for a laboratory test or
a clinical observation and
is a number with up to seven digits.
While the codes themselves
are deceptively simple,
they contain a lot of information
detailed in their names which,
as shown here, are divided into five or
six main parts separated by colons.
In this example of the first part
the analyte, our substance of interest,
is glucose.
We can see that it was determined two
hours after the patient consumed 100
grams of glucose because the first part
of the name is divided into subparts,
separated by a caret.
Here there are two subparts,
but there could be three.
The first subpart, glucose,
could also contain multiple levels
of increasing specification
separated by dots.
The third and fourth parts,
the time aspect, Pt,
means a point in time
rather than a time range.
And the system sample,
Ser/Plas, indicates
that the test was performed on the serum
or plasma components of a blood sample,
can be modified by a separate subpart,
again separated by a caret.
This table is a more detailed
explanation of each of the parts
of the name.